Having a problem with the right machine that I on Pro8 works, no problem with the ball is totally dead and does not light it off.
Okay, I called right and they want me to send in the ball and the right machine. Have you seen this happen? How long do you think it'll take to get my right back?
So if the ball is totally dead and it won't light it all, you could have just a problem with the ball.
I don't know enough about the internal component set to know if the ball, if the ball programs would, would not work if the, if I, if I approach it receives like if I am pro waves working it's not the machine.
It would be the ball that's my fault.
But, you know, there, yeah, we've had people have problems with the ball, typically it has to do it like they trip over the court or something like that and pull the, the, the court out at the, at the glass, you know, tube itself, or the solder broke and then the ball's not going to work.
They're not getting any frequencies.
When we first started with, you know, 12, 15 years ago, we had different issues that were corrected and never happened again.
That's probably the possibility.
It definitely said it in as fast as possible.
Typically they'll fix it, you know, that same day or the next day and send it back to you.
So it's usually a pretty quick turn around.
They better really good about that even with under new management.